como decía mi amigo el principito lo
esencial es siempre invisible a los ojos
en mi propia experiencia creo que el
mundo en el que vivimos nos ha engañado
un poco y nos ha hecho creer que el ser
es efecto de la sed y del tener hemos
sido condicionados inconscientemente a
creer que necesitamos tener ciertas
cosas o circunstancias o hacer o
desempeñar ciertos roles específicos
para poder sentirnos felices valiosos o
importantes de esta manera buscamos en
cientos de circunstancias externas aún
las más nobles casarme tener hijos
éxito profesional las causas de mi
felicidad
pero esto
nunca funcionará
nunca será suficiente porque vivimos en
un mundo que está sujeto a una constante
transformación
poner la causa de tu felicidad en
cualquiera de tus circunstancias
externas la condena a ser inestable y
fugaz de tal manera que el ser como
efecto del acero del tener no sólo es el
orden incorrecto de las cosas sino que
en verdad es el paradigma de la
verdadera infelicidad déjame te comparto
un poquito mi historia para que para que
puedas entender lo que quiero
transmitirte
he tenido la oportunidad de perder
prácticamente todo lo que el mundo
moderno me enseñó me haría sentir feliz
en esta foto puedes darte cuenta que lo
primero que perdí fue el pelo
cosa
que si soy honesto si fue un tanto
dramática
cuando aún caminaba por esta universidad
diciendo a un adolescente
perdí a mi madre de una durísima
enfermedad
un cáncer que durante dos años desgarro
y me hizo sentir triste impotente y
enojado
gracias a esta energía tuve la capacidad
de arrancarme la mayor parte de mi
sistema de creencias mis dogmas
limitantes y me di cuenta que con ella
se había ido la mayor parte de mi
sistema de pensamiento había quedado un
tanto libre y hoy por eso bendigo a mi
madre y bien dicen que dios aprieta pero
no ahorca si había llevado a la ala más
a la primera de las mujeres
trascendentales en mi vida pero había
llegado la segunda mujer trascendental
de mi existencia
frida
una mujer increíble maravillosa que me
ha dado la oportunidad y la bendición de
tener una familia primero con la llegada
de mi hijo juan carlos
y segundo con la llegada de mi hijo iker
parecía entonces que la vida se trataba
de un juego de ganar y perder de ir y
venir en el que habría que sobrevivir y
salir con un saldo favorable contento
finalmente con mi familia busqué en el
éxito económico y profesional la causa
de ser aún más feliz
en el año 2012 tuve la oportunidad de
perder absolutamente todo y caer en
bancarrota derivado de un fraude de casi
200 millones de pesos perdí mi casa mi
patrimonio mi dinero mi tranquilidad mi
prestigio
incluso mi propia libertad estuvo en
riesgo
frente a la idea de estar preso
es en verdad que recordé aquella frase
de lo importante es que tenemos salud
y es que hasta que no te ves en la
orilla del precipicio es que podemos
comprender en verdad lo importante creí
que había perdido lo más valioso que
tenía y me hacía sentir estable y seguro
pero frente a esa realidad pude recordar
y entender que no hay posesión material
ni rol profesional y social más
importante que tu propia vida que la
vida la salud y la libertad son los
baluartes más preciados y ahí entendí
además que nadie podía robarme mis ganas
de vivir y mi actitud de salir adelante
mientras tuviera vida y fuera libre de
poderlo hacer
me sentí sumamente orgulloso de haber
aprendido esa lección y casi casi como
recompensa a la lección está aprendida
sentí que recibí
el premio y la experiencia quizá más
fascinante y maravillosa que como
familia hayamos experimentado
la llegada de santi
mi princesa
la tercera mujer que cambió mi vida
al ser mis dos hijos varones
y no haber más nietas en la familia fue
la niña más esperada de los dos árboles
familiares
pero además mi esposa es la mayor de
cuatro hermanas de tal forma que desde
muy chiquita jugó con sus hermanitas a
que tenía en ella su princesa y su
muñeca de carne y hueso yo estoy seguro
que en esa edad nació en su corazón la
ilusión de tener a su propia princesa
no les puedo explicar la alegría y la
felicidad y el amor que santi sembró en
nuestro corazón con su llegada les
platico una historia el domingo 7 de
mayo del 2017 estábamos mi familia y yo
en puerto vallarta playas paradisíacas
todos juntos celebrando el primer
campeonato nacional de juan carlos mi
hijo
claro como buenos mexicanos en una
agónica serie de penales
como pueden ver en esta foto ese domingo
prácticamente me pasé jugando con santi
a enterrarla en la arena yo creo que la
enterré unos 25 veces papi otra vez más
y otra vez finalmente nos encontrábamos
juntos en puerto vallarta hasta los
abuelos estaban ahí
como diría will smith en la película en
busca de la felicidad a esta etapa de mi
vida le puedo llamar plenitud
el domingo 8 de mayo a las 8 de la
mañana
frida y yo llevábamos achante al
hospital a que le hicieran una revisión
por una obstrucción que había nacido con
la que había nacido en su corazón y como
ven en esa foto no tenía ningún síntoma
ni malestar había llegado con sus
juguetes feliz a un proceso de rutina
que había que practicarle para poder
diagnosticar la gravedad de la lesión y
saber cuál era el procedimiento que
teníamos que seguir
lo que incluía una operación a corazón
abierto dos años ocho meses yo venía de
la felicidad total de lo que tenía en mi
vida
a las nueve y media de la mañana del 8
de mayo de exactamente hace 2 años el
doctor salió del quirófano
para informarnos que el corazón de
santín había colapsado
santi había fallecido de un infarto como
causa de una reacción alérgica al medio
de contraste
en ese momento todo lo que en mi mundo
exterior me hacía sentir feliz se
colapsó
mi corazón entero estalló en mil pedazos
y con él la realidad
el domingo yo había jugado a enterrar en
la arena a mi hija hasta el cansancio el
martes lo único que me quedaba de ella
era arena y polvo
todo rastro de alegría y de felicidad se
había ido
por supuesto que el sentido de la vida
también nada de eso tenía sentido
no entendía en verdad de qué se trataba
la vida
quiénes somos y qué hacemos aquí
aquí comprendí que toda tragedia toda
desgracia
esas noches obscuras del alma traen de
manera dolorosa e incómoda
pero también valiosamente profundo
profundamente valiosa
el cuestionarnos el sentido de nuestra
vida
y el para que la queremos usar
contestar estas preguntas no solo se
hizo insoportable y urgente sino que
encontrar las respuestas trajeron a mi
vida una conciencia distinta y me
permitieron llenar de propósito mi vida
y de esto les quiero platicar perder
primero a mi madre
pero recientemente a mi hija
me llevo a mí ya mi esposa a una
búsqueda espiritual profunda como nunca
antes la había vivido y como estoy
seguro que sin su partida jamás lo
hubiera hecho
esta búsqueda espiritual desesperada por
respuestas que aliviarán mi dolor
hizo florecer en mí una conciencia
distinta
me abrió la mente a una realidad mayor
desperté a la conciencia espiritual de
lo que realmente somos y esta
consciencia me permitió ver con claridad
y certeza en mi corazón las señales
de que la muerte jamás bajo ninguna
circunstancia es el término de la vida
que solo es un paso de transformación
más que quienes se han ido están más
vivos que muchos de los que estamos aquí
y esas señales me recordaron que
nosotros no somos el cuerpo
nosotros no somos nuestro dinero ni
nuestra imagen ni nuestros roles
sociales ni nuestro prestigio ni tus
followers ni tus likes no somos
absolutamente nada de las circunstancias
externas con las que nos hemos
identificado y confundido
por el contrario como dije era mi amigo
el principito lo esencial es siempre
invisible a los ojos pero sólo a los del
cuerpo
para los ojos del alma la realidad
florece
en verdad pude entender que la esencia
de lo que somos es el alma sagrada que
trasciende el tiempo y las
circunstancias que somos esta energía y
conciencia que le da vida a esta
maravillosa experiencia llamada ser
humano
y que como expresión divina tiene la
posibilidad de hacer de este lugar un
paraíso terrenal
regresar a esta conciencia me hizo
sentir feliz importante valioso pero aún
no sabía del todo que iba a ser con eso
así que buscando más respuestas me topé
con víctor frank y aquel maravilloso
libro el hombre en busca del sentido en
el que narra de una forma maravillosa la
experiencia que vivió en los campos de
concentración en su libro leí que no son
las circunstancias de la vida las que
atormentan al hombre sino que es la
falta de sentido frente a estas
circunstancias las que lo derrumban y
aquí quizá comprendí la más maravillosa
de las lecciones y es que la vida no
tiene
ningún sentido en particular
por lo contrario es la vida misma la que
te hace esta pregunta cada instante y
circunstancia qué sentido me vas a dar
qué sentido le vas a dar a esto
especialmente a la tragedia a eso que
llamamos desgracia porque es en verdad
en estas experiencias dónde está la
oportunidad de encontrar nuestra
verdadera esencia así que descubrí que
somos completamente libres de elegir el
sentido de nuestra vida
ya había regresado a la conciencia de
que soy una expresión única y sagrada de
un campo infinito de posibilidades y
frente a la libertad de elegir el
sentido que él iba a dar elegir la que
más me inspiraba
elegir la que más me inspiraba y ahí
encontré una fuente de felicidad
infinita en hacer solo solamente lo que
más me inspiraba y elegí asir de mi vida
y de mi experiencia el mayor pretexto
para convertirme en el mejor ser humano
posible para ayudar a otro ser humano en
desgracia trascender sus circunstancias
a recordarle que está aquí como
expresión divina de posibilidades que no
son las circunstancias otra cosa más que
una excusa para recordar la grandeza que
nos sostiene porque cuando todo por
fuera se colapsa es que nos acordamos de
ir a buscar la fuerza interior de la que
somos de la que estamos hechos
así que
nació en mí
este deseo ferviente de ayudar a los
demás
y entonces elegí dedicar mi vida por
completo a inspirar y elevar el nivel de
conciencia de esta nuestra gloriosa y
hermosísima humanidad para poder
construir la realidad que tanto
anhelamos de tal manera que entendí
el propósito de la vida no es ser feliz
sino que ser feliz es tan solo una
posibilidad de aprender a vivirla y
aprender a vivir les abrazar todas y
cada una de sus experiencias con la
certeza en el corazón de que están
hechas para transformarte en la mayor y
mejor versión de ti
y que aprender a vivir les llenarla de
propósito
y allí encontré en el propósito de hacer
de este mundo lo que santi hizo conmigo
que es llenarme de amor de alegría y de
conciencia encontré en el propósito de
dedicar mi vida a llenar este mundo de
amor de alegría y de conciencia
la fuente inagotable de la felicidad
me di cuenta que por más que el mundo
exterior se colapse y se pierda lo que
tenemos y lo que hacemos jamás podemos
perder lo que somos
y en el centro de nuestro ser está
nuestro corazón y en él
encontré la riqueza la felicidad y la
importancia que había buscado fuera
porque en él encontré mi capacidad de
amar de servir de crear de construir de
inspirar a cuantos seres humanos pueda
vivir una vida increíble y
extraordinaria a pesar de sus
circunstancias y eso es a lo que hoy
dedico mi vida como fuente inagotable de
felicidad y que comparto con la
bendición de tener a mi familia
y tú
ya sabes quién eres
y para qué estás aquí
[Aplausos]